happy I got to ask you you did a Lego  short a short film very popular you  played a chicken what was the what was  the idea behind and was it hard for you  to do the votes voice vocally of a  chicken it was interesting I got in  there and it was just me and Charlie the  director and I'm just conversing with  Jackie Chan as this chicken and it's  it's been difficult I've been typecast  as chicken since the thumb came out but  like you know actually it's going pretty  well it's going pretty well  there's a lot of roles for really  amazing chickens you'd be surprised so  look out for oh but uh yeah I basically  just bought I popped popped dialogue  right over and over again and did you  have to do new on a block yes charlie it  would get you got very emotional it's a  cat-and-mouse game me and and Jackie  Chan and I had to I'd box like the  direction would be like pock like you  finally found her destiny  [Laughter]  [Laughter]  [Applause]  you